don't you guys want to hear a rap about
volleyball said with the panache and
aplomb of some what do you you a big fan
of volleyball
what type of volleyball oh not beach
volleyball really just a normal one
where they've got clothes on Chris
because I'm not a perv but go back to
England then we don't have beaches in
England we are we are cold we have white
cliffs got lovely so a volleyball but
not the creepy kind front two rows here
what you guys want to rap about there's
some whispering going on what is this
what what's that
frisbee are you a you an Ultimate Team
you are I would have guessed yeah these
guys pretty cool this guy straight up
nerd so volleyball bin or the creepy
kind frisbee word from anyone I come
from this side wow we are getting some
men giving some kind of unexpected
things volleyball through food court
wheels I like it don't want that
retrograde masculinity in here yeah down
with the patriarchy back at the room
this is your time to shine what would
you like a rap about yeah and again just
complete opposite just a delicate woman
going wheres career I like it
whiskey you have a particular favorite
type of whiskey Kenny well my kind of
gal and let's take a let's take the
final one this Candice this could be a
challenging one as well cuz so far these
are all great suggestions but they're
all kind of you know the things we know
you know things like um like Geographic
sinkhole locations or Afghani irrigation
ditches what cut up panties in the trash
I hope that is a reference to someone's
joke from earlier and not something that
you just had there because if so run run
far away as fast as you can
volleyball but not the creepy kind
frisbee whiskey of any type this is
wonderful
cartwheels and cut-up panties in the
trash do you want to drop that beat good
sir this is a little thing called a
freestyle rap there's a rap made up on
the spot based entirely on those
suggestions and do not worry it will not
be anywhere near as atrociously
embarrassingly bad as here expecting a
29 you're all privately educated middle
class white boy to be and you can pump
up a little bit as well yeah I'm kind of
close to the buts that's how a far feel
clench my ass cheeks when I car we will
make sure I feel so aerodynamic I have a
problem I can tumble when I don't really
plan it I like to get my hands grip yes
I can talk I get the white powdery
substance called chalk I can car wheel
for a very long while I do more flips
than Simone biles she's the best
athletics the best eye aerobics if
you've done a cartwheel then you will
know it's very hard at the point where
you don't know where the ceiling is
which was the sky which one's the floor
I asked a quiz of anybody the car wheel
is whiskey especially if you're drunk or
hungover from whiskey because then you
might fool your guts go up your
esophagus and then you blow chunks
because you've agitated or your
digestive system if I'm doing air robux
in the gym and people know damn stinking
the booze they stay away from me because
man food tubes are liable to go and this
takes a jack daniel´s that they've gotta
wipe down the machines with the flannels
and let's say it's good for your health
and that's why man and has whiskey on
every shelf in the kitchen she's got the
Irish one too who was a good brand maybe
tell a more Jew and other types Guerra
could go on the war on by talking about
Kentucky for one
I know it's bourbon I had to say it
differently and when I'm playing my
favorite sport it's frisbee people
look at me we can catch my eye and say
did you know that started out because
someone had a pie dish yes I know
don't try and spoil it they had a fresh
pie then with a foil bit on the balm
people took it with ease and said all
run their awaited the trees and catch
the frisbee they run away that's their
job it's basically a sport but it's
meant for dogs why would you play it I
really don't know it frustrates me that
people say all teammate frisbee Ultima
it's ironic yo cuz it's not the word
mate in it but you probably don't know
anyone who wants to be friendly with you
I'm very sorry for being roasty at you
your friends volunteered it they were
all whispering saying yeah let's take
the piss from him we're gonna say
frisbee play mum blast next thing you
know I'm up to the task I'm gonna talk
about volleyball but the good kind not
the one I like with my filthy mind you
know ha I love it I view it obscenely
I'm there with my lubricant while
they're in bikinis saying yeah it's the
best of all I love the waist all sweets
go handle the ball one of them sets one
of them spikes I'm sure both of them are
probably I won't say that word it's a
homophobic slur but back to the
volleyball that you prefer the one is
played in a room played in a core for
this rap I'll probably be put in core
and that would be the worst thing damned
so pathetic y'all I'm going down to
diving after this festive ball with this
guy yeah him and me we go in rummaging
for cutter panties why are they sliced
up yeah with precision someone's gone at
this thong with the pair of scissors
getting all the G strings cut in them
with cleavers saying throw it out
panties I don't need you in the garbage
disposal where the hobos go and they
hold the panties to their nose probably
is disgusting why do we discuss things I
don't know who why the heck did you even
bring this up basically they should be
worn as underwear and like a raccoon
going rummaging for underwear under
there
all the boxes and empty coke cans eeeh I
keep it in lock and key because I don't
want people to find out a weird fetish
of sliced up underwear is about probably
something that I'll say with the grin it
probably dates back to something that's
quite Freudian there you go
[Applause]
[Music]